حسنًا، أنا أتحدث الفرنسية الإنجليزية الجزائرية
اليابان التي هي خليط من اللغة العربية
البربر وفرنسا لذلك ليس لديه ما يفعله
انظر مع العربية الحرفية
[موسيقى]
كل ما يجعل محمد إنسانيته
قدرته على مسامحة الناس
ترتفع لتصبح أكثر حكمة كل هذه
يشكك في حياته وقوته
المرونة ومن الواضح أن فهم
كل ذلك ثم نعم
كلاهما جزء
التعذيب حيث شعرت بأنني مضطر لذلك
أنه لم يكن لدي خيار سوى الذهاب
أقرب ما يمكن إلى الظروف الحقيقية
أن روحي ويجب أن تعبر إلى
تكون قادرة على أن تكون أصيلة كما
ممكن
هذا النظام الغذائي الذي يفعله يسوع في وقت قصير جدًا
الوقت وتفقد الكثير من الوزن
كتيبات تكبل الخلايا الباردة
وأخيراً تعرضوا جميعاً للتعذيب
الأمر كله يتعلق بحقيقة أنها كانت جلسة تصوير
مركزة جدًا لدرجة أننا أطلقنا النار عليها
25 يوما أعتقد من الاثنين إلى السبت
في بعض الأحيان بعض أيام الأحد 12 ساعة في اليوم
كان هناك يوم دون استراحة الغداء
حقا شيء جيد
أكثر من مكثفة بالنسبة لي
[موسيقى]
إذا لم أكن أريد أن ألعب دور الإرهابيين
انها ليست بالفعل بداية
ثم له طريقة السينما
وقال ويتعلق بشكل خاص
قادم من إرهاب هوليوود وأنا لا أفعل ذلك
لا أعتقد أنه يتغير حقًا
العقليات التي تصنعها حقًا
نفكر بالطريقة التي نريدها
الأمور متوازنة في رأيي
ولهذا السبب أردت أيضًا
لا تفعل ذلك ثم لم أرغب في ذلك
ليتم إلقاؤها أيضًا ليتم تصنيفها
ولكن هذه المرة ليست أ
الإرهابي هناك إذا أبلغت نفسي و
يجب أن أسأل نفسي هذه الأسئلة متى
قرأت وأين أقول لنفسي ولكن ربما
أن هناك خطأ في كل لعبة ز هنا لدي
فعلت واجباتي المنزلية التي درستها طرحتها
الأسئلة ونانسي هولاندر هي
حتى أنه قال أنه لو كان هناك عدد قليل
دليل على أنه بعد الكثير
لسنوات سيكون شخص ما موضع ترحيب ل
واحد لتكون قادرة على إظهارها
يجيب عليك بطريقة عامة إلى حد ما
لكن لا يوجد فيلم قمت بصنعه
أنني لم أختر ليس هناك واحد
الفيلم الذي صنعته وأنا نادم عليه
مهما كانت النتيجة البعض
أكثر نجاحًا من البعض الآخر
شوهد أكثر من البعض الآخر
يتردد صداها أكثر من الآخرين إلا أنا
طريقي من الممثلين إلى طريقي من
المطاحن التي أشعر بالأسف بنفس القدر
أنه لا يوجد فيلم أنني رفضت ذلك
أتأسف
[موسيقى]